in this video we're going to go through
three different kinds of examples
involving writing the standard form of
the equation of a hyperbola when you're
given certain bits and pieces like maybe
they're given the vertices in the foci
or the asymptotes or like a point on the
hyperbola just some various information
so I'm going to assume that you know a
little bit about hyperbolas in this
video and then we're going to kind of
take it you know to writing the
equations but we'll go through it as we
go through some of the different
examples some of the key components of
hyperbola so let's dive into this first
example and we'll kind of talk about it
as we go we're just given the vertices
and the foci and we want to write the
equation right so let's draw a graph I
always recommend just drawing a graph it
doesn't have to be like perfect or
anything but just so that you can kind
of see what's going on so 2 4 and 6 4 3
4 5 6 4 is right about here so these are
our vertices and then our Foci are at 1
so I'll label that f for Foci and 7 4
right here F so what that tells us just
by graphing these points is that we can
see that our hyperbola is going to be
opening like to the right and the left
okay like that
and so what that tells us is that it's
going to be in this form here where the
x squared term is the positive term it
comes first if it was opening up and
down like this one here then the Y
squared term would be written first and
what we can do now is we can find the
center point right here which is halfway
between the vertices it's also halfway
between the foci you could use your
midpoint formula or if you have a good
graph you can just you know count but
let's just do the midpoint so 2 plus 6
is 8 divided by 2 is 4 and 4 plus 4 is 8
divided by 2 is 4. so that means that
our Center is at 4 4. now when I like to
write these equations I kind of like to
piece it together as I go what I mean by
that is I know this is going to be x
minus the x coordinate of the center
minus y minus our y coordinate of the
center okay squared it always equals 1
for hyperbolas and ellipses right but
what we have to figure out now are the a
squared and the B squared now what is
the a squared present well the a is the
distance from the center
to the vertex so this is your a and in
this case you can see that's from 4 4 to
6 4. so you can see we're going two
units so our a value is equal to two
let's write that down
now the distance from the center to the
foci that distance is C so C is going to
be from 4 4 to 7 4 so that's a distance
of three
and B is this distance here okay when we
draw that rectangle we use the corners
of the rectangle to draw our asymptotes
that distance there is B but there's a
formula you want to memorize for
hyperbolas and that's c squared equals a
squared plus b squared so in this case
to solve for b we have c squared is
equal to a squared which is 2 squared
plus b squared
is equal to c squared and c squared we
know is three so let's uh change this to
3 squared so that comes out to 9 equals
4 plus b squared subtract 4 from both
sides and you can see that b squared is
equal to 5. so we can see in our
equation here B squared is five a
squared is 2 squared which is four and
you've got the equation of your
hyperbola in standard form let's take a
look at another example okay example
number two is a little bit different in
the sense that they're giving us the
vertices and a point that the hyperbola
passes through so how do we get the
standard form of the equation of this
hyperbola again I would recommend
drawing a sketch we've got the point
negative 1 3 which is going to be one of
our vertices and the other one is at
negative 1 negative seven which is right
about here
and you can see that the point that it's
going through is 1 4 right about here so
what this tells us is the graph is going
to be opening in the what I like to call
the y direction basically up and down
okay in this vertical Direction which
means it's going to be in this form
right here where the Y squared term
comes first it's the positive term
so the next thing I'd like to do is
maybe find the center point and the
center is halfway between the vertices
so you can use the midpoint formula or
you can just count on your graph so it
looks like this is going to be at
negative 1 negative 4 divided by 2 would
be negative 2. so basically just add the
x's and divide by 2 add the Y's and
divide by 2. that's our Center
now because it's in this form I would
like to start putting it together so
I've got y minus the y coordinate of the
center so that's going to be y minus
negative 2 or Y plus 2 squared minus x
minus the x coordinate of the center so
that's going to be x minus a negative 1
which is X Plus 1 squared and hyperboles
always equal 1. remember the distance
from the center to the vertex that
distance we call a okay distance from
the center to the vertex and so that is
going to be a squared is our denominator
here a is the distance from let's see
negative 2
okay to negative 7 that's a distance of
5. so our a value is equal to 5. so 5
squared is going to be 25. all we have
to do now is solve for our B squared and
that's where this point comes in to play
so we know it goes through the 0.14 if 1
4 is a point on our equation here on our
graph then it's going to make this
equation true right so what we're going
to do is we're going to place
one for x and we're going to put 4 in
for y and we're going to solve for our B
squared so let's go ahead and do that so
if I put 4 here
and 1 here what do we get we get 4 plus
2 is 6 6 squared is 36. over 25 minus
1 plus 1 is 2 2 squared is 4 so that's 4
over B squared is equal to 1. Now 1 is
like 1 over 1 right so what we could do
here is we could actually clear the
denominators by multiplying through by
the common denominator which is 25 B
squared so let's go ahead and do that
multiply our whole equation by 25 B
squared if we do that here this is going
to come out to 36 B squared this is
going to come out to minus 100 because
you can see the B squareds cancel 25
times 4 and this is going to come out to
25 B squared so if I subtract 36B
squared from both sides to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other
that's going to come out to negative 100
is equal to negative 11 B squared
divide both sides by negative 11. so you
can see that b squared is coming out to
100 11. so we can replace B squared
squared with 100 11 or when you put a
hundred elevenths in here when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so if we
want to write this kind of as a neat
form of the standard form of the
equation of our hyperbola this would
really look like 11
X Plus 1 squared
over a hundred
equals one or if you don't like that you
could just write the hundred elevenths
in the denominator and it's okay to have
that fraction there but this is just a
little bit
kind of Rewritten a little bit neater so
let's take another look at a different
example and number three
before we dive into example number three
if you're enjoying my channel and you
come back to see my videos now and again
consider supporting the channel by
joining as a channel member for a few
dollars a month you can help support the
content that I'm putting up here and I
really appreciate it let's take a look
at this last example though see if you
can do this one on your own this one's a
little bit different than the first two
in the sense that they're giving us the
asymptotes and the vertices so how do we
find the standard form of the equation
of this hyperbola again I would start by
drawing a little sketch so we can see 1
negative 2 is right here
and negative 3 negative 2 is right here
so those are our vertices
and we know that the center is halfway
between
the two vertices so you can do your
midpoint formula or you can just count
so in this case it looks like it's going
to be at negative 1 negative 2 so it's
just halfway between and we know that
this hyperbola is going to be opening
in the horizontal direction or what I
like to call the X Direction so it's
going to be in this form right here
so now we're going to do is let's go see
go ahead and graph the asymptote so y
equals 2x is going to be going through
the origin and it has a slope of 2. so
rise two run one and the asymptotes will
also pass through the center point
of the
you know hyperbola so that's important
and then over here the Y intercept is
negative 4.
see one two three four and has a slope
of negative 2 so that's going to be
going something like
uh like this
okay so now we have a rough sketch here
and you can see that the
um hyperbole is going to look something
like this where it approaches those
asymptotes
okay roughly like that so let's go ahead
and piece together what we have so far
so we know it's in this form we know the
center so this is going to be x minus
negative 1 or you could say X Plus 1
squared minus y minus negative 2 or you
could say y plus 2 squared equals one
and remember the distance from the
center to the vertex that distance is a
in this case that distance is
2 so a squared is going to be 2 squared
which is 4.
and then all we're left to solve for is
B squared now this is something that you
might want to make note of when you're
finding the
um asymptotes the ratio of the number
underneath the Y divided by the number
underneath the x is going to be the
slope of your asymptote now you'd have
to take the square root of these so it's
going to be when it's in this form it's
going to be a slope is B over a when
it's in this form here it's going to be
a over B the way I like to think of it
is the change in y over the change in X
okay is the slope right and so that's
why I think the number underneath the Y
over then underneath the x is going to
give me my slope of my asymptote same
thing over here the number underneath
the YB over the number of the X a so B
over a so in this case b over a which is
going to be B over 2 because a was 2 is
equal to the slope of our asymptote
which is
2 plus or minus 2 really
and so now when we cross multiply or B
times 1 is B and equals plus or minus 4.
but we're looking for B squared so plus
or minus 4 squared is going to be 16
negative 4 times negative 4 or positive
4 times positive 4 and that's our
standard form of the equation of our
hyperbola now if you want to see more
examples with hyperbolas ellipses
circles parabolas check out my conic
video right there where I go into more
depth about all the different conic
sections follow me to that video and
we'll get some more practice I'll see
you there